get ready to shoot you know what it is
take off these pants [ __ ] 88
degrees almost 90 in Los Angeles and
it's November the hell's that about
[Music]
what's going on you two you know they've
made quite a few things that's been told
to me before I started working out I'm
gonna tell you that personally there's
some of these things in just not true
now I might call some of these people
out there liars no but you are like a
techie okay maybe not alive but there
are a lot of people out there when it
comes to working out
they say [ __ ] like it's a universal
truth and that should make work on the
average human being I'm tell you
something right now that should know one
guy man for example you know when you
really feel like you don't want to go to
the gym to work out how many people have
said to you Amen all you need to do is
get to the gym and everything will fall
into place
trust me I know basic [ __ ] you might do
better than that you know who I am
I'm that dude that always gets hyped up
to go to the gym you don't buy stronger
than you [ __ ] you so cute and
one of the bigger reasons why I always
get hyped up is because I always see
shape the movie then I'm gonna be
remember when the movie 300 came out how
many of you [ __ ] I felt like a
little [ __ ] where's my quest bar but
the way [ __ ] about that even though I
get a hiked up she never goes down the
weights opposed to damn right you
feeling your walkies you got a long day
cool business you are using cute [ __ ]
ain't you morning feeling like P Diddy
oh no I fault I didn't fall asleep I'm
at the gym you [ __ ] me
fat boy and you know what's funny every
time we said if I hide you in to work
out suddenly a million excuses pop up
cuz even if we find a small legitimate
reason not to go it makes us feel better
that we skipped on the gym can't go
gotta take out the trash no gotta be a
good boy
oh no there's a force field I can't get
to piss I'm just gonna jack off as a
saying [ __ ] anyways okay this is what we
call a fat coincidence but though you
don't know if a coincidence is when you
make an excuse to why you're fat or why
you eat something in the beginning God
created heavens and a [ __ ]
dough to give me that [ __ ] at the end of
the day where you don't want to do
something you can always find an excuse
not to do it so getting into this whole
lifestyle of being healthier it was a
huge mental game cuz yeah I can
physically get out of my bed and get my
ass in the gym because if I don't get
this right this is doughnut shop right
next that [ __ ] just robbed me going
[ __ ] I'm pregnant no what the [ __ ] your
problem is your mouth and your body says
you want to be healthy but the real
question is do you so before you even go
out and look up workout regiments and
new dietary plans or whatever you need
to get your mind right first because all
that [ __ ] doesn't matter if you don't
commit here let us go with no so last
week you guys will ask me if you see a
transformation so yeah I lost 40 pounds
but I was really really really obese so
I'm from obese too less obese so here is
that transformation pic that you asked
for it is a rough rough journey but now
I'm a little bit more strict on my diet
and I am going to be more active so
let's see how far this takes us I'm
hoping to be at my goal by the end of
March so yes I'm trying to get there
sexy on with them so remember there's
gonna be a vlog this Sunday and a life
vlog this Friday so stay tuned and be
prepared with that it's gonna happen
it's gonna be poppin so I will see you
all next time try not to touch your dick
so much they might fall off not sure
that's true so funny fit fit fam
remember life is always with so funny
fat bit
and remember life is always what you
make it but it's up to you to take what
you deserve
let's go for Brooke the place this [ __ ]
you and when you're good